solo blog day 12
9:28 p.m. the dog likes to embarrass me
the dog makes a personal attempt to
embarrass me the primary function of a
walk is that the dog can take his [ __ ]
last night the dog took a [ __ ] on the
rug he's a ticking time bomb of fecal
matter it's very very very very very
very very crucial now that we get the
dog outside
now when we're on walks he likes to hold
it in and wait until a car is passing
and or a person then he'll take a [ __ ]
while they're passing backwards
situation when you're holding the leash
and on the other end of the leash that
you're holding is an animal taking a
[ __ ] there's no way to look casual I go
with a bag I walk with a bag I always
have this self-conscious hesitation fear
that people are watching me from their
houses to see if I actually pick it up
because that's something I would do
which is not saying many good things
about me I have now taken to this
technique of bending down and pretending
that I'm picking up the [ __ ] when
actually I've really just scooped up a
leaf the dog knows this tonight cliff
liked to take a [ __ ] on the lawn of
someone who was actually pulling into
their driveway he's up the stakes he
challenged me he's asserting himself as
the alpha male and I'm passive
aggressive I held strong I continued
with my fake [ __ ] picking up technique
and and it worked